[Música]
[Aplausos]
el mundo vivió una transición hacia las
megaciudades como epicentros
predominantes de producción y
administración económica el primer
modelo de esa tendencia fue un nueva
york que en los años 50 desde entonces
las urbes hiper pobladas son cada vez
más comunes en una década podrían ser
más de 39 los ciudadanos no buscan estar
es cerca de los centros productivos
entre los ejemplos está egipto que ya
alcanzó 20 millones de habitantes en el
cairo y que construye su nueva capital
en medio del desierto para evitar el
colapso indonesia también vive una
crisis en la isla de yakarta que se
hunde a un ritmo acelerado y que
sobrepasa los 10 millones de habitantes
ya así no es viable por lo que erigirá
en la isla de borneo a un xantar a su
capital del futuro la pregunta ahora es
cómo debe desarrollarse este nuevo
concepto de vida
según euromonitor de las cinco mayores
macro ciudades por población en 2030
serán yakarta tocó y tokio karachi y
manila y también el cairo pero también
se espera que se sumen a las
megaciudades casos tan diversos y
diferentes como bogotá de colombia y
bagdad en irak para la conversación a
nuestro invitado designación ortiz de
andrés ingeniero de caminos y canales y
puertos de la universidad politécnica de
madrid con especialidad en urbanismo y
ordenación del territorio ignacio
gracias a usted y empecemos hablando del
ejemplo de áfrica se prevén ciudades con
más de 80 millones de habitantes a
mediados del siglo el porcentaje de la
población urbana 78% todo eso con
pobreza crónica y con cambio climático
cómo será ese crecimiento
claro
angela encantado de saludarte y un
placer que me haya invitado france24
evidentemente cuando hablamos de
megaciudades pensamos en ciudades en
núcleos urbanos que tienen más de 10
millones de habitantes no para que se
sitúen telespectador y otras personas
y otros técnicos dicen que también se
tiene que producir una concentración de
esa población en al menos 2.000
habitantes por kilómetro cuando las mega
ciudades como bien decías en la
introducción la primera fue nueva york
en 1952 grados y millones de habitantes
y qué sucede pensamos en ver a ciudades
como nueva york tokio tokio que es la
primera que alcanza 40 millones en
economías muy desarrolladas pero cuando
más la pregunta por áfrica ya estamos
ante otro tipo de núcleo urbano con
mayores complicaciones si cabe y con
complicaciones o por ejemplo de
contaminación
como bien dices en aplica se espera por
ejemplo para 2050 que haya poblaciones
por ejemplo en lagos
una concentración enorme de hasta más de
75 millones de habitantes según avance
las décadas y ahí ya hay muchísimos
retos de salubridad
de depuración de aguas de
infraestructuras porque las ciudades
desarrolladas cuentan con
infraestructuras muy solventes que son
importantes pero en estas pues está el
término que se conoce como slum de
barrios degradados de chabolas etcétera
que hay hay grandes problemas entonces
es un reto muy importante tanto para el
país como para como como para el resto
del mundo hay ciudades desarrolladas y
también hay ciudades desordenadas las
seis nuevas megacities que se prevén
para 2030 incluyen a bogotá en colombia
a chennai en la india luanda en angola
salaam en tanzania y también en bagdad
en afganistán están preparadas
bien
realmente hay mucho reto hay muchas
cosas por hacer se puede decir que
muchas ciudades en los mega ciudades en
países en desarrollo no están preparadas
es estimadas en naciones unidas que al
menos 1000 millones de personas viven en
barrios degradados como puede estar eso
preparado no se puede
suficiente abastecimiento de energía en
muchas veces calles o carreteras sin
asfaltar un tejido que no responde las
calles a un trazado urbano homogéneo a
usos también por ejemplo angela usos
mixtos del suelo donde por ejemplo pues
una persona pueda trasladarse fácilmente
a su centro de trabajo sino que estén en
nuestras puntas y en otro lado el
suburbio donde se concentra
especialmente en las residencias o
extras en la vivienda hay mucho por
hacer hay grandes inversiones pendientes
tanto en infraestructuras en calles en
seguridad en servicios mucho
dinero y acciones que digo que en
ocasiones también
se extralimitan a la propia acción del
propio de la propia ciudad del propio
municipio y el propio país y que en
cierto modo pues tiene que tener un
apoyo internacional en casos de boise en
países donde están más en vías de
desarrollo si me permite la corrección e
ignacio facta desde irak y ahora si
pasamos a la siguiente pregunta una
razón para la migración a las ciudades
como pasa mucho en américa latina es el
conflicto armado cómo controlar en ese
sentido la densidad poblacional
rápidamente
bueno yo soy de la opinión que bueno
igual que los técnicos que es importante
que la población no esté muy dispersa en
el espacio porque las infraestructuras
ya no solo de transporte que por
supuesto sino también como digo de
energía pues es difícil poder abastecer
debe la población estar en una
determinada concentración de alturas
para conseguir la compacidad de la
ciudad pues a través de una política de
vivienda de vivienda protegida que pueda
en ciertos modos en soportar esos
desplazamientos que se producen muy
rápido en américa latina en estos casos
que me estás comentando pues quizás de
delincuencia
en determinados extrarradio zonas
alejadas de la ciudad pero ya sea del
ico en delincuencia o sea pues motivo
simplemente de que la ciudad se sume un
gran atractor de población y los núcleos
urbanos hoy quedan desabastecidos y si
es importante la compacidad y que las
administraciones públicas
correspondientes apuesten por esa
compartida para luego poder dotarlo de
infraestructuras de manera adecuada y ya
para el cierre muy rápidamente ignacio
vimos hace algunos años el ejemplo de
brasil ya que fue una capital
completamente planeada y construida para
ese fin ahora pasa en egipto y en
indonesia qué opina de esos planes de
reubicación
bueno a veces los municipios o estas
grandes macro ciudades tienen que
acostar cuando se les acaba el espacio y
bueno pues construir un hacia de nuevo
una expansión o lo que se denominan los
ensanches urbanísticos tan habituales
en todas las ciudades pero digamos un
ensanche enorme un planteamiento de una
ciudad ex novo en ocasiones en
grandes a grandes demandas en estas
ocasiones pues por lo justifica y es
importante la planificación previa es
una de las cuestiones en urbanismo
fundamentales no se puede construir con
esos asentamientos tan rápidos de los
que hablábamos sin planificación